l'enjeu il est pour le futur il est
double la nature du financement et sa
trajectoire à l'international la nature
du financement n'est pas une simple
posture la nature du financement des
conséquences immédiates sur le
rapporteur vous le savez à Berlin
nos amis allemands nous ont fait savoir
qu'une budgétisation c'était un flirt
beaucoup trop étroit avec l'État et que
ça n'était pas conforme à la législation
allemande donc on est avec une
démocratie sur notre tête on ne sait pas
si on ne va pas perdre notre fréquence
FM à Berlin qu'on a depuis 24 ans parce
que nous serions budgétisé
c'est quand même très embêtant sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut savoir que ruche
atoudet avait demandé que France 24 soit
qualifié de chaîne gouvernementale parce
que c'était une chaîne publique et non
justement YouTube a répondu mais non ils
sont ils ont un faisceau d'indices
d'indépendance la nomination du
président les modalités de financement
la loi etc si on fait sauter un
financement affecté
on est dans le même statut cruche à tout
des je me dis franchement donc il y a
pas de raison qu'on soit pas chez le
gouvernementale aussi et pour lutter
contre les infox franchement il y a
mieux quelle chaîne gouvernementale donc
faut-il faire une charte républicaine je
c'est une idée que j'ai mise
je pense qu'il faut une charte
républicaine de l'indépendance comme la
BBC en a une pour garantir à
l'international notre indépendance c'est
important mais le modalités de
financement aussi et la non
budgétisation
ce serait important même en principe en
position de principe parce que la FM va
être attribuée là elle va pas attendre
que on ait fini notre discussion donc
moi je demande au Parlement de nous
donner une position de principe pour
dire qu'on gardera une recette affectée
quelle que soit sa forme et après il y a
le la trajectoire et je cette
trajectoire je sais qu'elle sera
contrainte c'est pourquoi je redis ici
que puisque nos dépenses à France
médiumonde
sont calculés dans l'aide publique au
développement français à hauteur de 20
millions c'est-à-dire 20 millions de ce
qu'on fait et repris dans le calcul de
l'aide publique française de
développement je dis juste et bien
mettons les recettes qui vont en face de
ces dépenses en aide publique au
développement ça allégera le reste du
secteur et ça nous permettra de nous de
continuer à ne pas décrocher face à la
concurrence internationale alors même
qu'il s'agit à travers de l'ensemble de
nos actions de favoriser la Liberté
d'informer qui est un bien précieux qui
est le fondement de la démocratie qui
est malmené à l'échelle du monde
et c'est là une mission essentielle de
média de service public internationaux
français voilà je vous remercie